c'est istres et cela c'est bon ça quant
au bruit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
journée devant un écran
tout le monde dit que c'est indécent
lancez pas besoin d'elle en compte tous
pas crash mais défend
cette année sont cassés je vis de ma
passion sur cette affiche de ma
génération mensonge mairie flamand ce
qui m'arrive mais perd sa b3 bon moment
[Musique]
que tu fais car tout le monde ne dit pas
le faire qu'est ce que tu fais honte a
dit commente à ce projet aidera des gens
comment prendre du recul regarde autour
de toi t'es pas tout seul
[Musique]
bakou
mais qui fait de pseudo des lettres sur
cette joie des visages et des points
journée les gens sont plus d'amour qu'un
prématuré même si la télé continue
d'allumer le matin je t'ai lettre à
france soir et j'essaie d'être la plus
intense à court d'idées l'atout quittez
jamais dit moi jamais je vais faire avec
ça dans la vraie vie
braver tous les interdits éviter là mais
saisit tout ce que tu fais tout le monde
le dit pas le faire mieux que regarde
autour de toi
[Musique]
de simples promesses quel chemin
emprunter vouloir à tout prix pas
décevoir
on oublie l'essentiel cette soirée au
fond des tout simplement mais manquera t
vouloir à tout prix pas décevoir les
deux sens hier c'est soit tu es doute
sur ce que tu fais que tout le monde ne
dit pas le faire puisque ce que tu fais
car personne n'a dit comment faire quand
on voit surtout un projet ça fait déjà
des gens là dit commentaire
pour sa première cure regarde autour de
toi tais toi
[Musique]
pas cool
face trinité
[Musique]
mais
je
[Musique]